Vélez,
God, I
am,
ah,
this
is my duty, as
and Japan,
and
today,
6,
how
and
ah, and
I
ah
[Music]
and
God,
González, it has to be that no,
ah,
well, s
d, you
see,
for being perfectly
the sun, it's
easy,
the front, the envelope, but then you see
d
of scale
and it's not,
to this decision of protection and listener,
yes, they already
know,
and
then incision,
yes, no,
well
[Music]
above all because the water doesn't run
and
[Music]
oh yes
and
6,
I'm not in the center, they are
of eyes
in this version,
the emissions
3,
this vision,
this is not in
2,
and
well,
of bs,
but
the footballers,
ah
[Music]
the children
return,
if the author and Albert's family
before,
science
too
[Music]
without thinking
2,
yes, yes,
themselves,
young,
mine,
without knowing,
model
[Music]
is
and now
and once,
wyss,
total,
I
ah,
in this country
to come
and dishonest
[Music]
yes,
d
6,
well,
ah
Monza with Zparo
already
[Music]
is
prayer
yes
I returned
[Music]
but and and
ah and
and about knowing
and now well
[Music]
ah
and it is or but
insight
yes
[Music]
Télam
yes
t
[Music]
and it is to
return
Estevez anyone yes ah
well
thank you
more
read
things
[Music]
ah it wasn't like that yes
time
[Music]
yes it
will be the only one
and
in its time I want to be
these cement at 50
the country
on top
Watson
oh you
see
I am
yes
this I have dreamy
is the fourth year of cancer being all
web
and
[Music]
you can rest
Deluca
others
yes
and
and it arrives
h
well s as
where is it
no
well
and
counts
[Music]
and
in dreams
[Music]
dream
is to say
thing
Stein
and you
during this day
all
of
things well
where does
God smell you see
then
[Music]
today
ah yes
the tongue is to leave
the sporting
[Music]
rest
web version
or
and
say it's
my house
plus
the racing dreams
he
[Music]
but not
a respite
solution with six sets
for an external shock
h
but
well
yes I i
if you look
and
space
I'm
William Gray
m
later
in dreams
wasting
[Music]